as neurotics on the left and even on the
right suffer a nervous breakdown and
horde warehouse is full of toilet paper
the Trump administration implements
policies that actually help stop the
spread of wool banach plague we will
examine why hysterics don't help during
a pandemic then Joe Biden confuses every
major disease of the past decade while
duking it out with Bernie Sanders Ronald
Reagan's son proselytize us for atheism
during the Democrat debate and the left
takes advantage of the global panic all
that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
we're still here they haven't stopped us
from broadcasting yet even though the
mayor of my city Eric or city of Los
Angeles is doing everything he can to to
screw up things in the city this is a
man who couldn't could not address the
homelessness problem he allowed
homelessness to grow 16% in the course
of one year this is going to
dramatically accelerate the spread of
this crisis but he's shutting down my
favorite bar
great job mayor Garcetti well luckily he
has not been able to stop us from
broadcasting so that's very good very
glad to be with you all as other shows
on more left-leaning networks are
shutting down we until they force us
will not be before we begin I have to
start with a PSA if you are getting
hysterical stop it stop it come down
don't do it it's very very annoying and
it's not helping anybody
there is no reason ever ever to get
hysterical
there is no reason ever to panic you
know there are people especially on the
left right now especially if you go on
that god-forsaken hellscape of
twitter.com who are saying that if you
are not panicking if you are not getting
hysterical if you are not saying that we
are on the verge of civilizational
collapse then you're not taking this
seriously you're not you're risking
lives you're a very very bad person
you're you're not supporting public
health actually if you are panicking if
you are freaking out if you are losing
your mind and hoarding warehouses full
of toilet paper you're either one of two
types of people you're a cynic trying to
exploit this for political advantage a
lot of people are doing that on the left
we'll get to a lot of that today or
you're a neurotic and there are a lot of
those going around too either way you
are not helping you're making things
worse so everybody just let's take a
little sip take a little sip of our
coffee whatever we're having
inhale-exhale and let's hope we didn't
get the plague on anybody there
is context here for everything so what's
the update the update on the coronavirus
is the death toll is 61 61 million not
61 thousand not 6161 very sad that
number is going to get bigger it is
definitely going to get worse all true
still for context before barack obama
ever publicly acknowledged the swine flu
h1n1 a thousand americans had died that
was before he said peep about it we are
shutting down the global economy and the
u.s. death toll is presently 61 not
saying that we shouldn't take
precautions just giving you context for
calm now there is cause for concern
right now over a thousand people have
died in Italy
now there's also cause for context here
so Italians are the oldest population in
Europe they greet each other by kissing
and they haven't had a functioning
government since Octavian none of that
is to say we shouldn't take the
coronavirus seriously
all of that is to say the United States
is not Italy these are different places
with different context also worth
pointing out the United States is a far
superior health care system to Italy and
the rest of Europe also worth pointing
out where did the virus begin in Italy
where did the epidemic spread what was
the first region under quarantine the
region was Lombardi and this the city
was Milan now that's unfortunate for
labias Milan is Italy's capita economic
capital why was that the first city to
shut down well because over the past six
seven eight years Milan has imported
huge numbers of low-wage Chinese factory
workers and they were running regular
flights to places in China affected by
this disease the other reason is they
did not act nearly as quickly as the
Trump administration to shut down the
borders get control of this crisis
so people are seeing the number of cases
increase and they think that we are on
the verge of social collapse here the
data do not show that hopefully later in
the week we'll be able to take a deeper
dive into what the numbers show
especially when we have more reliable
but what we do know is that the spread
of the disease is tapering off
everywhere in the world the rate of
acceleration is tapering off everywhere
in the world why is that because viruses
don't grow in a straight line forever
it's not like a virus enters a country
and it's like just just takes off like a
rocket ship and that's it and it never
tapers off or it gets exponentially
worse viruses just naturally grow they
accelerate the accelerate accelerate
then they plateau then they decline this
is a phenomenon that's been observed for
a long time it's called FAR's law you
can rest easy this is not going to grow
and accelerate forever and that's not
even based on changing our behavior
that's just let's say we didn't change
our behavior whatsoever it would still
accelerate plateau and decline and we
are dramatically changing our behavior
because we're trying to slow as best we
can the acceleration of that that virus
according to the World Health
Organization if you come in contact with
somebody who tests positive for the wolf
flu do you know what your chances are
not of dying not of being hospitalized
do you know what your chances are of
even catching the virus between one and
five percent that's like you're there
you're hanging out you're shaking hands
you're buddy-buddy with somebody who is
sick with the bubonic plague your
chances of getting it at all
one in five percent error based
transmission virtually impossible you
are not going to catch it from somebody
because the virus comes out of their
mouth and grows wings and flies over to
you now if you spits on your face you
might catch up air base transmission of
this very very unlikely is this
contagious yes it's more contagious than
the flu from the data that we see but
it's much less contagious than say
measles or a Zika virus or other public
health problems we've had what is the
government doing to handle this they're
doing a lot and they're doing a very
good job and this is working people on
the left this Trump is rising to the
occasion we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over we
the people holsters in times of crisis
before I go out and buy water and food I
want
make sure that I've got ammo and a gun
and when you're carrying your gun you
got to make sure that you've got a very
good holster starting at just $37 we the
people holsters are custom designed to
fit your firearm perfectly and they are
made right here in the USA I think we've
learned over the past few weeks how
important it is to have things made in
the USA not rely on places like China to
produce our products for us we the
people holsters have thousands of
options to choose from for both inside
and outside the waistband plus a great
selection of printed holster with
everything from the Constitution to thin
blue line their designs are great they
have designs to show your support for
our president their proprietary clip
design allows you to easily adjust both
the Canton ride of your holster so that
it will fit comfortably and securely at
all times go to We the People holsters
comm slash Knowles get yours today every
holster ships free comes with a lifetime
guarantee then you get an extra ten
bucks off with offer code Knowles so now
you're down to 27 bucks satisfaction
guaranteed that's not a perfect pick
send it back for a total refund we two
people holsters dot-com slash Knowles We
the People holsters comm slash no let's
don't forget that offer code Knowles to
save another 10 bucks ok what is the
government doing to handle the Chop
fluey president Trump has given several
press conferences now you remember he
gave a speech from the Oval Office the
Oval Office speech was a little mixed
reviews ok
the Oval Office speech basically seemed
good
you know the words seemed right and yet
there was something a little off about
it
Trump seemed a little more nervous than
he usually does he usually seemed so
relaxed and easy with the audience and
with the camera some of the facts that
were given out during the Oval Office
speech turned out to be not exactly
correct they were imprecise for instance
he said a travel ban will go into effect
at midnight on Friday now midnight is
technically the start of the day so be
it
you know 11:59 Thursday night then
midnight Friday is one minute after that
but he actually meant the day later so a
lot of people didn't know about the
travel I actually had relatives who were
in Europe they didn't know what that
meant so was a little confusing and the
markets tanked during that oval office
speech so Trump decided to have another
go
and he had a press conference in the
Rose Garden on Friday the press
conference in the Rose Garden on Friday
was excellent we'll get to specifically
why it was but just what he announced
there he declared a national emergency
which allowed states and localities to
access up to fifty billion dollars to
combat the spread of the virus that was
very smart he and his task force the
coronavirus task force announced
partnerships with certain companies that
allowed for commercial laboratories to
produce a lot more tests and it allowed
for them to be available at drive-in
testing sites like Walgreens and CBS and
Walmart all really good news the way you
know that that press conference worked
you don't need to take my word for it
the markets rallied markets jumped two
thousand points during the press
conference it was really really good I
was sitting in a green room actually at
Fox here in Los Angeles and I was
surrounded by Democrats and even the
Democrats were saying oh yeah this is
better okay this is cool you can see the
market rallying up the way you can tell
that the left is being disingenuous here
in their coronavirus criticism is they
keep moving the goal posts that's how
you can tell if you don't believe the
market if you don't believe your own
lyin eyes the way you can tell that
Trump is actually doing a good job here
is the left keeps changing what they're
complaining about so initially the left
was complaining that Donald Trump closed
the border with China early on when this
virus broke out
Trump shut down travel from China public
health officials now say CDC everybody
says that romantically helped slow the
spread of the disease and saved lives
when Trump did that the left attacked
him they attacked him they said it was a
terrible idea
and that it was xenophobic and that they
wouldn't have done it and I'm not just
talking about random blue checkmarks on
Twitter I'm talking about the
presumptive Democratic nominee for
president
Joe Biden and I was like this this is
where the credibly a president is most
needed as he explains what we should and
should not do this is no time for Donald
Trump's record of
nasteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia travel restrictions based on
favoritism in politics rather than there
it is he doubled down on it so he says
Donald Trump has this awful record of
hysterical xenophobia what he's
referring to here is President Trump's
decision at that point to close the
border with China this is no time for
that well imagine if President Biden had
left that border open how much worse off
would we be today
how much more like Italy will we look
today Italy took the Biden route how's
that working out for Italy America took
the Trump route we're looking pretty
good Italy has a thousand deaths the
United States has 61 two visions right
so they attack him for that
then they attack Trump for not doing
anything he already done a pretty big
move then they attack him for not doing
anything but right now he obviously is
doing something you've seen all the
press conferences you've seen the new
policies coming out of the
administration so now they can't attack
him for this in a phobia they realized
that border thing was a good idea they
can't attack him for doing nothing he's
doing quite a lot he's holding daily
press conferences so now they're
attacking him for the last thing that
they possibly can at their disposal
which is that everybody in America
hasn't been tested for this virus yet
there hasn't been massive nationwide
testing but the thing is and even some
conservatives are getting confused on
this point so hear me out
the thing is not everyone needs to be
tested most likely if you're listening
to this show you don't need to be tested
you don't have any symptoms you don't
need to be tested even if you do have
symptoms and you're young and healthy
and self-quarantine
you probably don't even need to be
tested you're good the people who need
to be tested or the people who are
really at risk here of complications or
even death they're the guys who need the
tests they're the ones who need the
hospitalization Trump even made that
point in the press conference we'll get
to that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over a rock auto listen man
if I got to get the heck out of Dodge I
need to make sure my car is working very
well and luckily I've got a wonderful
auto parts store in rockauto.com
rockauto.com so much easier than walking
into an old
brick-and-mortar and trying to get
answers to the questions that the people
at the brick-and-mortar aren't going to
be able to give me they're not gonna be
able to give me the parts they're just
gonna go online probably rockauto.com
order the parts and charge me a lot of
money it is impossible to keep track of
every auto part it's impossible to
figure out exactly what you need but if
you have the Internet then you have
access to rockauto.com at your desk and
in your pocket and then you really do
have access to all those things the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
especially for me someone who doesn't
know a lot about cars very easy to
navigate I really love these guys going
over to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck right Knowles Cana wles and there
how did you hear about us box and that
way they will know that we sent you
rockauto.com and right in Knolls so
trump makes this point in the press
conference the point that the left keeps
trying to to trick us about the left
thinks that everybody in this country
needs to get tested immediately for
coronavirus not only is that not
necessary that's counterproductive that
would be a waste of tests a waste of
time and a waste of resources Trump
gives you the real story I want to make
sure that those who data test can get a
test very safely quickly and
conveniently but we don't want people to
take a test if if we feel that they
shouldn't be doing it and we don't want
everyone running out and taking only if
you have certain symptoms the left loses
their mind over this they say oh how
could you say that you're encouraging
people not to take public health
seriously you're you're not panicking
you're not being hysterical and that's
really bad for some reason well you
don't need to just take Trump's word for
it one of the stars of the corona virus
epidemic one of the few people in the
administration that the left even the
left will admit is this very serious
incredible person is doctor foul Qi
doctor foul Qi is a guy he's on the
corona virus task force this guy has
been a major public health official in
the United States for decades and
decades he was a major figure during the
AIDS epidemic and he's just got
credibility all around Universal respect
so he's been very helpful for the
administration here because he's on the
task force he's not just some Trump
appointee or a Trump loyalist he really
is has his own reputation in his own
career he goes on CNN and makes exactly
the same point about testing that Donald
Trump did I want to take a look at this
picture you actually touched the same
podium I'm sure you've seen this in
microphone as the president and other
CEOs even at the same time the vice
president has taken a test for
coronavirus he tested negative negative
I should say his vice president pants
have you taken a test are you going to
take a test no well I'm not taking a
test for the summer breeze I have no
symptoms I have not I'm practicing
pretty good social distance I don't go
but it's hard to not only do it is but
not everybody in the United States
should take a test I mean I have no
symptoms there's no reason for me to
take a test if I'm in a situation where
I'm at a higher risk I will take a test
the picture you showed about the
microphone let's get real here I mean
there are certain things is you have to
do if I left the microphone at that you
would see nothing but the microphone my
putting my two fingers to get the
microphone down is it that bad so I
don't think we should make something of
that I'd like to see people more doing
this as opposed to shaking hands there
is a voice of reason when somebody is
talking that way when somebody is calm
when somebody is balanced that's how you
know you're listening to a voice of
reason when some blue checkmark is
screaming their head off about how the
world is ending which by the way they do
every single other day right they say
the global warming and the Sun monster
gonna kill us in 12 years anyway we'll
get to that in a second actually one of
the sort of benefits of this panic is it
is exposing some of the left-wing
hypocrisy and disingenuine about all of
this
disingenuous does read all of this
hysteria so we will get to that but he
makes a great point if you don't need
the test then don't use don't get the
test right pretty basic the the key here
is to remain calm okay and he's doing
that he's a public health expert he's
not just a random blue checkmark on
Twitter I do trust that guy he's got
universal acclaim so for us
from about a successful press conference
he then moves on to a second successful
press conference because during that
first one in the Rose Garden the stocks
ran through the roof we jumped 2,000
points and so he said gosh that worked
well I guess I should do another one so
he olds the second one this is in the
press briefing room and he says another
wave of calm he puts another puts water
on the flames here and he says guys you
who are all running on the stores and
who are buying up all the toilet paper
calm down you don't have to buy so much
they gotta work 24 hours around the
clock keeping their store stocked I
would like to say that people shouldn't
go out and buy we're gonna all be great
we're gonna be so good we're gonna do
what's happened with the Fed is
phenomenal is what's happening with all
of these incredible companies and
phenomenal is but you don't have to buy
so much take it easy just relax people
are going in and they're buying more
they I remember I guess during the
conversation Doug of Walmart said that
to buy more than they buy a Christmas
relax we're doing great it all will pass
exactly relax it'll all pass I mean this
is the trouble right now right now we
have 61 deaths right very sad but
manageable right now we everything is
fine if you look outside it's not just a
barren wasteland everything is fine
except if people change their behavior
too radically if they start hoarding
food if they start to panic if they
become hysterical then we're actually in
a real problem because you can't get
food or tea you're seeing that in a lot
of stores these not a lot of food on the
shelves we went to the store last night
and thankfully people in LA are just
totaled dholtze because they bought up
all the chicken and the beef and the
pasta and they bought up all that but
they left my favorite vegetable broccoli
rabe so those rubes aren't going to get
delicious bitter greens well I'm having
a nice quarantine still even beyond that
you need to remain calm so president
Trump was joking about this he was like
look at me I'm cool as a cucumber the
markets are reacting really well to this
maybe I should start holding one of
these every day I was honored to see
that the stock market
you were mostly there with us set a
record in a short period of time over a
45 minute period that we had the press
conference yesterday in the Rose Garden
that's it I was a record all-time record
I think we should do one of them every
day perhaps how about every about five
times a day will do one five times a day
yeah but that was something to watch and
I had no idea we walked back I said so
how did that work out they said sir you
just said a new record in the history of
the stock market so that was pretty good
that's pretty good I love that I love
that he's taking these digressions
because if you only are focusing on one
minut part of this you're at risk of
screwing up everything else this is true
in general you know what the left really
likes is experts very often their
experts don't know very much they don't
have a lot of expertise but they're
experts you know they've got the glasses
and the diplomas on the wall and what
the left believes is that if you just
put the experts in charge of everything
then we'll have the perfect government
then we'll have utopia on earth the
leftist believe this since at least
Woodrow Wilson so if you put the global
warming expert in charge of all global
warming policy then you'll get the best
global warming policy and and so on and
so forth actually the opposite is true
the opposite is true because human life
is very complex because politics has a
lot of moving parts and if you only
focus on one aspect of it you become
myopic and you wreck everything else so
if all we're focusing on now if the only
thing we do and we devote all of our
resources to it is to stop the spread of
the virus to zero which is impossible
that will not happen it cannot happen
but if we focused all our resources into
doing that and we were willing to trash
the entire economy destroy civil
liberties destroy our system of
government in order to do it that would
be a bad thing we would all agree that's
a bad thing but in the moment the people
only focused on the this one aspect of
the crisis like robots who were only
programmed to do one thing at a time if
you if you did that you could make a
strong case we have to do everything and
we have to do everything we can to focus
on this one aspect everything else be
damned but that wouldn't leave us
well off Trump knows this so he's kind
of focusing on the economy during the
press conference he's focusing on how
well his press conference did he's
making a couple jokes it's good to make
a couple jokes during a crisis the best
moment of the press conference was when
he's walking out of the press briefing
room he took questions you know
interesting to note that this
administration which the left hates and
they say it's secretive and opaque this
is probably the most open administration
of my lifetime right he's taking direct
questions from the press he's holding
his own press conferences in the
briefing room and so he takes a bunch of
questions then he starts to walk out and
you can hear at the very end a reporter
shout out mr. president have you taken
your temperature is your prep is your
temperature normal and this guy has such
a he pauses right before he walks out
the door just turns theatrical hand next
to his face he goes totally normal bye
see ya walks right out
it's like he might as well have just as
he's walking away from the room just lit
a match thrown it back the whole thing
explodes isn't such a cool way to walk
at and all of us should be cool as well
in these crises so that we don't all
panic this is the right attitude to have
on the whole damn thing totally normal
we're good calm down keep calm and carry
on like the Brit said during World War
two keep calm and carry on is very good
advice the Brits are known for their
stiff upper lip but now in America then
our indulgent and neurotic culture we
are of the opinion that we should never
have a step up to stiff upper lip we
should be indulgent we should whine we
should be wimpy we should be neurotic no
don't do it we need to have a little bit
of courage that is the prerequisite for
all the other virtues alright enough on
the wolf loop we've got to get into the
Democrat debate most people don't even
know there was a democratic debate last
night we'll get into Biden versus Bernie
what it means for the race what it means
for the not just the Democratic race but
for the general election we'll get into
all that we will also get into how the
left is taking advantage of this whole
crisis but first a daily wire membership
is the only way you should be viewing
our content okay simple as that
you're missing all the best features if
you're not on Daily wire calm right now
using promo code knowles canna wles you
will get 10% off any member plan you
choose this is my gift to you in
self-quarantine
what makes memberships so great well
members get our articles ad free they
get access to the daily wire app and all
of our live broadcasts in full show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show select bonus content access
to the mailbag and more plus our new
all-access tier gets you into exclusive
live online Q&A discussions with me
Andrew Clavin matt walsh ben shapiro
everybody plus daily wire writers and
special guests and don't forget you'll
also get the greatest of all beverage
vessels the leftist ears tumblr you will
get that all of that plus 10% off when
using promo code Noel's keno wles
so stop depriving yourself and come join
the fun head over to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
alright the democratic debate we're not
gonna spend too much time on this
because frankly as I'm watching it last
night I couldn't tell who was gonna fall
asleep first me or Joe Biden or Bernie
Sanders is really boring and you know
those guys have like 70 or 90 or 120
years on me so kudos to them for staying
awake when I barely could Joe Biden God
loved him he opened up the whole debate
which was going to criticize the Trump
administration response to coronavirus
by coughing into his hand what do you
say to the American people who are
confronting this new reality first of
all my heart goes out to those who have
already lost someone or those who are
suffering from the virus sorry I I got a
little lump in my throat let me just
Koff on my hand my other hand hey Jake
Tapper do you wanna you want a shoulder
massage or do you want to like nuzzle or
kiss or anyway I don't know well anyway
we got to take her on a virus seriously
pretty hilarious way to start off kind
of a cheap shot people are doing this
people are still shaking hands people
are still coughing but anyway not a
great look for Joe Biden Biden was then
asked how he would address the wuhan
virus and his answer did not instill
confidence because he confused every
major public health crisis of the last
decade so we should already be sitting
down and planning where we're going to
put these temporary hospitals and we can
do that we did that we've been through
this before with the corona virus we've
been through this before army skooby
we've been through this before with
dealing with the viruses that the n1 h15
as well as what happened in Africa we
provided these hospitals dealing with
these great pandemics and we were able
to do it quickly and people would have a
place to go how is this guy supposed to
beat Trump the left's argument against
Trump is that he doesn't know anything
and he's not specific and he talks too
loosely and he's too general and he's
ignorant and Joe Biden is that all of
that turned up to 11 he opens up by
saying look we can deal with coronavirus
because we've dealt with it before we've
dealt with it with coronavirus know we
had
we have definitely not dealt with it
with coronavirus uses no I don't mean
coronavirus I mean what the other one
the other one the n1 h1 so that's not
what it's called the what he's referring
to is h1n1 which is also known as the
swine flu and everybody knows that
people should know that people running
for president should know that but
especially joe biden should know that
because he was vice president during the
h1n1 outbreak that was swine o9 it
happened during his and Barack Obama's
first year in office couldn't remember
that then he couldn't even remember the
name or an anagram of the name of the
other public health crisis when he was
vice president Ebola
he called it what happened in Africa he
called it the the outbreak in Africa
something to that effect he didn't call
it by its actual name Ebola virus named
after the Ebola River did not instill a
lot of confidence and then because this
was also taxing on Joe don't forget Joe
Biden wanted to sit in an armchair
during this debate that was the original
discussion with CNN was the Biden
campaign was pushing for Sanders and
Biden to sit in chairs during the debate
because the Biden campaign didn't think
Joe could stand up the whole time
luckily Joe did manage to stand up the
whole time but when he when he kept
flubbing all of his answers he
eventually said to Bernie Sanders that
he didn't want to talk about politics
during the presidential debate look I
this is a national crisis I don't want
to get this into a back-and-forth in
terms of our politics here I don't want
that look I'm he I'm just here to eat
ice cream and watch some reruns of
magnum p.i alright I'm not here to get
into a back-and-forth about politics if
you want to get to a back-and-forth
about politics you got to go to a
presidential debate where are we wait
what oh sorry go to Joe three oh three
three three oh you are at a presidential
debate to go back and forth about
politics actually this is a broader
point even on the whole coronavirus
epidemic a lot of people right now are
saying we shouldn't have any political
disagreements on coronavirus we all need
to just be totally united and usually
the people who are saying this are
saying we need to be totally united
behind left-wing policies
they never want to be totally United
buying the president but they want to be
totally united behind left-wing policies
now it's true that we should probably
dial down the partisan ranker because we
are facing danger right now but we
shouldn't get rid of politics politics
is a good thing in a self-governing
republic you need politics politics is
how we all decide how to live together
when we all have different perspectives
and different points of view when you
get you know what gets rid of politics
totalitarian regimes they get rid of
politics a lot they do not allow you to
engage in politics because they tell you
exactly what to do now maybe some people
maybe some of our friends on the Left
wouldn't mind that so much but I
certainly would mind it and this idea
that we listen we need to get rid of the
politics and just do what I say that's
that's not how things work here in
America sorry buster sorry leftists
generally and sorry Joe Biden
specifically now Biden did make one good
point during the debate and really only
one he pointed out that socialists are
exploiting the coronavirus and he didn't
do it quite that explicitly but he may
as well have he responded to those
socialists calling for medicare-for-all
saying the corona virus proves we need
to get completely Nix our health care
system which is by far the highest
quality health care system in the world
and we need to move to a
medicare-for-all socialist health care
plan
Joe Biden said wait a second you know
what country has Medicare for all Italy
and Italy is dealing with this crisis
worse than anybody due respect to
Medicare for all you have a single-payer
system in Italy it doesn't work there it
has nothing to do with Medicare for all
that would not solve the problem at all
absolutely right a really good point and
Bernie Sanders for his part by the way
could not answer the question listen to
him Babel and Babylon Babel if you were
president right now what would you do to
make sure every sick American is able to
get treatment so the u.s. does not
suffer the same fate as Italy where
doctors have to decide right now who
gets life-saving treatment and who does
not Jake let's be honest and understand
that this corona virus
pandemic exposes the incredible weakness
and dysfunctionality of our current
healthcare system now we're spending
twice as much for personal and health
care as the people of any other country
how in God's name does it happen that we
end up with 87 million people who are
uninsured or underinsured and there are
people are watching this program tonight
and say I'm not feeling well
should I go to the doctor but I can't
afford now did you notice and that whole
rambling answer it goes on for like
another minute or two you notice what he
didn't answer
Jake Tapper's question he can't address
the problem of Italy all these leftists
who say we need a socialist health care
system look at how terrible the American
healthcare system is we've got 61 people
that have died from this virus unlike
Italy with a socialist health care
system that has over a thousand wait a
second maybe they haven't paid attention
to that Bernie Sanders doesn't have an
answer and nobody else does either you
know we try to take your questions if
you are on The Daily wire app or website
so please send them in before the end of
the show especially this week when
somebody shows her off and information
is hard to come by a question now from
KP is Bernie signaling he's going to
drop out of the race he didn't act like
he really wanted to harm by maybe he's
not signaling that he wanted to drop out
of the race I don't think he's signaling
that he's not running to get the
nomination he's not gonna drop out he is
trying to force Joe Biden into a leftist
box that's the ideological reason that
he's staying in the race he knows that
he's got some popularity in the
Democratic Party and so he wants to
force Joe Biden to adopt some of his
policies I'm not saying he didn't want
to harm Joe Biden last night I think
that's bringing it too far I think he
wanted to pressure Joe Biden and like if
this were a totally hands-off I'm about
to drop out and endorse you Joe then he
wouldn't have made these points he
called at one point he called Joe Biden
a liar actually we'll get into that in
just one second so I don't think he he
went easy on Joe but I think he wasn't
hard-charging in thinking that he's
going to get the nomination he wants to
make Joe Biden more left-wing and he's
gonna stick in the race because Joe
Biden doesn't seem to have all his
marbles he doesn't have a lot of
physical stamina and there's a
chance that he will just physically not
be able to be the general election
nominee in which case if Bernie Sanders
has more and more delegates he'll be
able to force the Dems to give him the
nomination so he doesn't have a huge
chance to win but he is pushing Joe and
one of the reasons I say he didn't go
easy on him at one point he called Joe
Biden a liar
my lord Bernie you're on an ad saying
I'm opposed to Social Security that
PolitiFact says there's a stack flat
line and that the Washington Post said
is a flat lie oh well let me ask you a
question Joe yeah you're right here with
me yeah have you been on the floor of
the Senate you were in the center for a
few years yeah time and time again
talking about the necessity with pride
about cutting Social Security cutting
Medicare cutting veterans programs no
you never said that no all right America
go to the website right now go to the
YouTube right now dishonest totally
dishonest and and Joe Biden knows I mean
Joe Biden's held every side of every
single position so Bernie landed that
flow Bernie landed another blow on him
which is Bernie has been saying he
doesn't have any super PAC supporting
him so Joe Biden thought that he could
get him on this he say you have nine
super PACs supporting you Bernie and so
you're a liar and then Bernie comes
right back at me cuz I don't have nine
super PACs Joe says you want me to name
them Bernie says yes and Joe can't do it
you get rid of the nine super PACs you
have tough nights apply to either side
mommy listen oh yeah you go ahead let's
go come on give me a break no I vote
won't give you a break on this one oh
it's so embarrassing Bernie totally
called his bluff and then Joe Biden just
had nothing so yeah you want me to name
him yes I would like you to name them ah
anyway it's just oh you don't want to be
in that position don't offer to do that
if you can't actually accomplish it a
question right now from MK Michael
should we keep calm and pray to the
thing should I hold this truth to be
self-evident we should certainly pray to
the thing as Joe Biden says the way that
you can tell Democrats are disingenuous
here the way you can tell that the Lib
are not being serious here this is my
favorite takeaway from the whole debate
in order to pump up the Wuhan virus
panic they are ignoring their previous
panic of global warming remember global
warming was going to kill us in 12 years
10 years 18 months some said well they
sure ain't acting like that now remember
we remember it was like pretty much a
felony to use a plastic straw in
California you could get fined it was a
big deal yet to use those stupid plant
paper straws that would just melt in
your mouth while you were drinking
through them now oh boy everything's
plastic they're going out to the stores
first of all they're buying every roll
of toilet paper that has ever been
produced in the last 10 years that can't
be very good for the environment it's
not great for the trees but what's gonna
happen to the trees then they're buying
plastic gloves they're buying PRL if you
go to the stores right now all the
organic food for the earth kind of stuff
it's all still there you can buy it it's
on every shelf
you know what's gone all the artificial
plastic chemical you know why because
that stuff works and there are no
environmentalists during a pandemic that
is simply the case and it shows you look
if if the wuhan virus at the worst case
predictions are it infects a small
percentage of the population in a
serious way and it kills a small percent
of them let's say let's say that overall
60 to 70 million people get infected at
some point with this virus and let's say
even doomsday scenario two percent of
those people die I'd be very sad that'd
be very scary but according to global
warming within 18 months to 12 years
we're all going to die so surely if
you've got those two crises you're not
going to buy the toilet paper and the
latex gloves in the Purell you are
actually gonna disavow all of that
because you've got to save the earth
right except that that's not what
they're doing because nobody really
believes this global warming stuff that
panic in many ways like this panic is
simply being used to push through all
the leftist policies that the left
really really wants and that they wanted
for 100 years and you can see this
pretty clearly
right now in New York City the New York
City Schools are as a largest school
system in the country are shutting down
okay fine I don't have I don't think
that's necessarily a great idea but fine
that's their choice
however the schools are going to remain
open for several hours per day to give
meals to the students who rely on those
meals okay I guess that's a good thing
right because they make the point for
many of these students the only meals
that they can rely on or given to them
by the government at school this raises
another question why are there so many
children whose parents aren't feeding
them we're a very rich country even
people who are at the very bottom of the
economic totem pole here have enough
money to feed their children peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches but with the
left doesn't want that the left doesn't
want to have strong families and strong
local communities the left wants a
government solution to everything so
that they have control because the
government - that's big enough to give
you everything you want is big enough to
take away everything that you have so
it's exposing some issues here you know
one takeaway I think from this from this
coronavirus might be as we look at the
school system in New York and elsewhere
what's wrong with these horrible parents
who aren't feeding their kids if you
can't feed your kid if you cannot give
your kid the basic amount of food your
kid should be taken from you how's that
for a government program because these
people it's not like these people are
walking around in rags with nothing to
their name okay
very often you see at the in terms of
bad parents here
they've got cell phones they've got
luxury items one or two I'm not saying
they're living like the Rockefellers but
they've got enough to feed their
children and if they don't feed their
children then the solution to that is
not for you and I through the government
to feed their children
maybe maybe look maybe we should take
care of all the children in the world we
should give to charity we should be very
generous but we should also take care of
the policy problem which is that we are
encouraging parents to abandon the basic
responsibilities of parenthood
before we go two things really struck
out at me here one from the left one
from the right during the democratic
debate the American Atheists ran a
commercial and the commercial was
touring Ronald Reagan's son who is
famously very left-wing and very atheist
so Ron Reagan jr. aired a commercial
about how he doesn't fear hell how there
is no god and nothing really matters hi
i'm ron reagan and unabashed atheist and
I'm alarmed by the intrusions of
religion into our secular government
that's why I'm asking you to support the
Freedom From Religion Foundation the
nation's largest and most effective
association of atheists and agnostics
working to keep state and church
separate just like our founding fathers
intended please support the Freedom From
Religion Foundation Ron Reagan lifelong
atheist not afraid of burning in hell so
first of all the things he's saying
about the founding just are simply not
true
and the things he's saying about our
government are simply not true but
beyond that we'll save that for another
day this is exactly what people want to
hear during a global pandemic right they
just want to hear there is no God there
is no hope there's no meaning to
anything and we're all going to turn to
worm food that's that's exactly what we
want to hear read the room libs are you
insane this it's not helping it's my
biggest takeaway from the left I look at
the left during all this I say like
you're not helping
you are freaking out you're running
around like a bunch of hysterical people
you're saying that there's no hope
you're saying everything's terrible the
civilizations gonna collapse and it
doesn't even matter if it does because
we are nothing but dirt and worm food Oh
give it a rest contrast that with the
conservative response during that
wonderful White House press briefing Ben
Carson was one of the people there he's
one of the most famous and accomplished
physicians in the entire country and now
he's the Secretary of Housing Urban
Development and he was asked his take on
the situation and he didn't focus on the
medical response which is good there's a
good medical response right now he
didn't focus on the
response also very good economic
response the Fed is cutting rates
there's quantitative easing the markets
are rallying he I mean the market is
gonna go up and down and up and down
over the next couple weeks but at least
they've responded well to the
announcements from from the White House
he focused on the spiritual component he
said you know President Trump declared
Sunday to be a National Day of Prayer in
in this crisis and gosh you know who
would have thought of that during a time
of great trial and uncertainty and
crisis
maybe we should pray to God I mean I
know who did know that our founding
fathers and before them the people who
settled this country people on the
Mayflower and pretty much every American
leader up until like 50 or 60 years ago
they all understood that but President
Trump is bringing that back making it
cool again and Ben Carson thinks it's a
wonderful idea you know we as a nation
can use this as an opportunity to pull
together for good now President Trump is
going to be recommending a National Day
of Prayer and you know we've gotten away
from prayer and faith a lot in this
country there's nothing wrong with godly
principles no matter what your faith is
loving your neighbor caring about the
people around you're developing your
god-given talents to the utmost cities
become valuable to the people around you
having values and principles that govern
your life those are things that made
America zoom to the top of the world in
record time and those are the things
that will keep us there too yeah man
that's right you got it
I love even not just what Ben Carson
said which I agree with but the way he
said it
ben Carson always says this calm about
him even if he's angry
even if he's critical even it's there's
this level calm and I think of all the
great saints of history and and I I mean
literal Saints as well people who are
being fed to lions you know early
Christians they were come people being
flayed alive they were calm they might
not have been happy about it but they
were calm the great leaders the great
statesmen of history have remained
calm even when they're up against the
wall even when they're angry even when
they're fighting there is a level of
serenity to them all right they're not
freaking out they're not whining they're
not hysterical they're not neurotic that
isn't helpful and so when you you're
gonna see a lot of people on TV and in
the news and write for office and the
next in the next few weeks and some of
them are going to be mature and
responsible and calm and they're gonna
offer their solutions and some of them
are going to be streaking and trying to
convince you that the world is going to
end if you don't give them every single
political advantage that they want if
you don't give the left every single
thing they've asked for for a hundred
years their demeanor tells you a lot
about them do not listen to the
neurotics and the hysterics they will
only make things worse
Keep Calm carry on this too shall pass
and we'll be here with the show until
mayor Garcetti drags me out of my studio
all right that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen